I just want to say I'm not trying to say
that if you're white you can't complain
I'm just saying that if you're black you
get to complain more right because you
can't tell the band that
because you can't you get this right you
can't take people's like historical
context away from them everybody wants
us to like white people are always like
come on it wasn't us like they want
black people to forget everything like
every year white people had a hundred
years - how long ago slavery was I've
heard educated why people say slavery
was 400 years ago know it very wasn't it
was a hundred and forty years ago that's
- 70 year old ladies living and dying
back to back by ago and it's not like
slavery ended and then everything has
been amazing like it's just glad that's
over
oh yeah just ended like a clean where
you don't have to wipe just phone
you gotta you gotta remember that if you
mean a black person they have gray hair
they remember a time they weren't
allowed to use a certain toilet so give
them a little you know time to be cranky
and by the way white people have our own
thing that we stuff the week we're sure
that that hurt us that we have to cope
with like when they took our slaves away
that was really
so it's pretty even and so good so it's
even yeah it's even and white people
that slavery [ __ ] [ __ ]
I need mad at y'all about that for real
you know saying black people we be
[ __ ] with y'all about this [ __ ] cuz
ain't a brother/sister in this room that
has been a slave
we ain't none of us picked no [ __ ]
cotton we wouldn't have known [ __ ] about
it if y'all hadn't have made the movie
roots now [ __ ] up right there wasn't
like they taught it in school chapter
seven slavery jabbed a beater [ __ ] is
they never taught us we make [ __ ]
movie roots came on that shocked the
[ __ ] out of every black man in this room
and one which is like what what the [ __ ]
that's hot Wars you know that remember
white people y'all remember the next day
we came to school and beat the [ __ ] out
of ya I know that's a traumatic
experience you have to remember
and y'all gave brother some [ __ ] up
choices man everybody's the same we'll
chop your dick or your foot you know
everybody's late go right here man
all right here I'll do what you gotta do
man yo saying that's an easy choice to
make cuz you can hop over to some [ __ ]
you can't show up with two good legs and
no dick and that phone drive was a
[ __ ] yo Sam that was some [ __ ]
up bad [ __ ] man that boat ride cuz it
ain't like it is today you know saying a
couple of weeks from here to Africa and
these cruises playing shuffleboard and
[ __ ] these [ __ ] was at the
girli of the ship down the bowels
you don't saying change to eat y'all the
hundreds of [ __ ] just chained
together with a little diaper [ __ ] on
y'all saying that was a year long ride
cuz then were selling ships and the wind
don't blow all the time you're saying
you know he's sittin down there man the
mother
will you stop swinging your leg
I'm chanting you every time you swing
your leg my leg go up - and you why
you're [ __ ] all the time I'm not the
only one [ __ ] we're real Smith on
the [ __ ] maintainer you Chyna him
chained it Leroy gained the title came
to Shaka Zulu we are chained together
nama done [ __ ] right to you my telling
you now your stink I'm not the only one
[ __ ] look at you you're taller than
you were yesterday
stacking [ __ ] on top of shits on top of
you
[Applause]
some gold-plated chains would make a
nice retirement gift for a very very
good slave well this are you serious
well this was asking us jobs and this
can take the job like that in you but
what I don't understand myself as an
African is widely the slave masters go
all the way to Africa
you polish it here drivers going missing
was right next to the excise I with the
Texas though looking for racism about
two months ago and a showdown in Texas
got off the plane his [ __ ] walked up
looking for isms and my friends always
home you better go to Texas there [ __ ]
yo and we're in a month my modern-day
brother here that she'd do just what
they [ __ ] nobody
brothers acting like they couldn't have
been slaves back 200 miles ago it ain't
like the [ __ ] didn't like that
[ __ ] I wish I was asleep I was [ __ ] my
dog she tell me the man some
[ __ ] tight and I would have
been on the street and [ __ ] really came
home say a yo [ __ ] a barrel is cotton
horses suck my dick man
barring a [ __ ]
to enlightenment the first do two got
off the boat said that [ __ ] man let God
[ __ ] you [ __ ]
my legacy will banish it just
just keep that [ __ ] [ __ ] away from me
I got off the [ __ ] plane walked
up that I've walked up my bag my home my
black [ __ ] on black leather big ass from
a Diana [ __ ] on like this blue white do
all them said this your bag so James my
[ __ ] bag my [ __ ] a black man
have a suitcase
I hate how much fun black people to have
recently man this is I can say anything
I got down I want racially and lied
about this idiot take it yeah I am evil
yes like I don't even say for the night
oh my god I love I love the low ratio is
it look man you know let's be fair I
mean honestly be nicer with the racial
game I mean it I like to talk to you
know why people vote being honest about
Obama you gave it a shot you did you
gave it a two-year shot like oh yeah I
tried I tried to reach my I did but
she's not it's not it's just it fell
apart it really it really did and I'm
gonna tell you something you don't know
about black folks we will be on your
side then you're talking about you will
be on your side a lot more if you would
uh you know just not ever talk about how
you feel about anything
racial we catch up to you now serious
cause black people on the edge of
there's too many white people outwardly
hated them so we can we go who shut them
you shut up I'll be a distant light stop
rallies and I'll kind of start telling
you I'm this close to I'm mad at them
because I thought I would have a white
slave but I thought I was Benji's day
but I have me a white family Oh big old
fat white girl go warm my bed up
downstairs Susan
wall might better feed my baby with your
giant right titties and go outside and
stay a husband in the faces decide
whether I'm gonna sell them or not and
you know your wife's upstairs warming up
my bed you know that right
as I'll call the Vienna that's
uncomfortable I see someone wrote you
something about an article that I read
Oh my family's slaves article yeah yeah
that was an intense article I wonder
what does this person say it can you
read the question yeah that's what I was
gonna do can you not sit on the recorder
again alright my family
slaves article Hey bilbo baggins
longtime listener first-time mail I read
an article written by Alex Tizen he's
dead now okay that shocked me but didn't
really necessarily surprise me and I
love your cultural the cultural
perspective on it oh my god this is so
[ __ ] long in this article this guy's
talks about his family owned a slave for
50 years even after immigrating to
America they smuggled her with them and
all that they treated her like [ __ ]
never paying her forcing her to sleep on
top of laundry I imagine it's the dirty
laundry why would you want to have
somebody and constantly beating her for
the tiniest of errors only when the
writer grew up with an American identity
that he realized with what they were
doing to the poor woman wasn't right did
he and his sibling confront their
parents over this clothes great my
teacher that's not right as a guy of
Chinese descent raised in the Americas
raised in America I've witnessed poor
people like this firsthand
growing up visiting family back in Hong
Kong I'd see my cousin there Millennials
by the way being tended to by a young
Filipino girl no older
in 20s I never thought much of this back
then looking back it seems pretty [ __ ]
up
I asked my mother about these kinds of
people and she simply said that's just
the way things are these girls are poor
they need to support their family and
that's the only kind of shitty
employment that they can get once my
grandfather took me past City Hall in
Hong Kong on a Sunday and I saw hundreds
of young Filipino girls just sitting on
the ground doing absolutely nothing I
asked him what was that all about
he said that Sunday was the day off and
they had nothing better to do than
loiter they sent all their money back
home to their families so it's not like
they could shop a little restaurant or
anything they ate and slept with their
employers I never seen my grandfather
turn his nose up at a group of people
like that but ever before my grandfather
whose parents were murdered by the
Japanese during World War two oh wow
yeah I read about that [ __ ] the way the
main King ever read that [ __ ] the
[ __ ] Japanese went off and had to
walk to the orphanage after finding out
Jesus Christ I've got an easy life one
of the kindest most empathetic old farts
I know loved randomly hugging right
people he called them hellos because
that's what they'd say to him one of
these people out here's the article I'm
just curious what something like you
raised with purely western-centric
ideologies who would say about something
like this that well I mean this country
was kind of built on that I can't really
step away - well we don't do it anymore
[Applause]
yeah obviously I think it's I mean not
now but you should read the article it's
it's pretty powerful that whole thing
because this woman was given to his
mother by her father and their Filipino
and that's just yeah they were just like
here this person is going to take care
of you so she kept this woman throughout
her life and it became her children's
care keeper because she didn't want to
do any [ __ ] work and then she moved
to America
my god I gotta take these kids out for a
Sunday no no that's again that's just
like the culture like this person is
your nanny and now like you inherit them
or something like that so it wasn't even
as if she had it's just part of their
tradition I have to me like all of that
this guy grew up and then he realized
that this woman wasn't getting paid and
all this other stuff and he didn't
realize until it dawned on him like she
is a slave and so he tried to make
things better for her in her later life
after his parents died and all this kind
of stuff ya know but by that time she
you know didn't know any other life so
she didn't really she wasn't like yeah
I've been waiting to go shopping at the
mall like this whole time this is so
[ __ ] said that's like it's very like
Dubai Dubai they tell all those people
east of there that hey man come on here
and help us build all these beautiful
buildings you make all this money you'll
get out of poverty then they get them
there and then they confiscate their
passports and it's just slave labor that
builds those [ __ ] places and then
they like the number one you only get
out of his they like commit suicide it's
[ __ ] brutal then you watch your shows
and the big balloon tinted [ __ ] go
over there to buy a [ __ ] bag not a
fan not fair dubai not a fan of dubai
why can't they be sinless like the
United States of America no that's all
horribly depressing and I don't know
what to tell you about that as far as
like I don't know how you do that to
somebody there you go and there goes the
comedy right out the window
I wonder why I'm just curious of why
this person asked like I'm curious what
someone like you raised with purely
western-centric ideologies would say
about something like this again it's
like are you forgetting that this is
America that was built yeah but I didn't
grow up with that so what he wants to do
is get an outside perspective it's
actually an intelligent thing I mean
like hey I'm not from here I grew up
here but you know I also have
connections you know back there so what
do you think about this and blah blah
blah you know what I think I think it's
a terrible I'm gonna go on a limb and
say that that's [ __ ] terrible
Oh bah nope we undies the undies
everyone needs a slave the Ruby undies B
undies work until they're in the grave
no balls feel nice and soft cuz they
polished him with the underwear they
made in that's [ __ ] evil but I'm
white it's part of my DNA
I'm really sorry all right the undies
hey but what do you think about life
long slavery and somebody's dreams being
crushed and so crushed that they don't
even have any dreams and they don't want
to do on a Sunday I'd love to hear your
Massachusetts Western take on that
disgust